[تصفيق]
أجنبي
إنه مجرد وقت رائع لمشاهدة
التاريخ ، أعني أننا لم نفعل ذلك في
حياتنا ، لذا قد لا نتمكن من فعل
ذلك مرة أخرى ، فهذه
فرصة فريدة من نوعها ، إنها شيء يحدث مرة واحدة في
العمر ، أعني أنه كان  أكثر من
70 عامًا منذ آخر مرة
حدث فيها شيء من هذا القبيل وهي مجرد
فرصة رائعة حقًا بالنسبة لنا للجميع
يمكننا جميعًا أن نجعلها تعمل هذه المرة للالتقاء
معًا وفكرنا لماذا لا نرى هذه
[الموسيقى] الأجنبية
إنها وقت كبير  لكي
نتطلع إلى ذلك ، فأنت تعلم أن كل
متداول في المدينة
يتمنى أن يحدث هذا ، فأنت تعلم أنه أمر
جيد حقًا للأعمال التجارية الجيدة
للمدينة
وللمجتمع المحلي وهو ملكنا وسيكون
ملكنا الخارق
[الموسيقى  ]
أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هو الرجل المناسب للوظيفة ، دعنا نضع
الأمر على هذا النحو وقد تابعت مسيرته
منذ أن كان هذا
العمر وأنت تعرف هذا العمر إذا كنت
تحب نعم أعتقد أنه
رجل رائع و  أنا فخور بأن أكون بريطانيًا
[موسيقى]
أجنبيًا